oh boy i don't know i mean how would how
would betty be remember i don't even
like to think of that i only like to
think of looking forward to betty um so
i you know but if if you know
one you know one day i imagine we're you
know that's going to be somebody's going
to have a lot of statues erected in her
honor you know and i'm sure that she'll
have some sort of joke about something
being erected
knowing betty
i'll remember her
personally in the experience that i have
i can only go by that i can't say how
other people will remember her but i'll
remember her because my animals will
live on through her
um
she named my dog she named one of my
cats
she'll be remembered as
one of the smartest funniest kindest
most generous women
in a business that doesn't normally
have that kind of
people in it
um but that's how she'll be remembered
gosh betty what can i say um
you are
you're my hero
you make me laugh you make me cry you
make me want to be better every day as a
person
um
thank you for
being everything and more that i always
wanted from the moment that i saw you on
the golden girls to
you know playing scrabble with you
behind the scenes on the lost valentine
um
i give you my heart and my love always
and
for me you will
be here forever so
lots of
she was a cockeyed optimist
but
she made always made the point that
if you look at those negatives you spoil
all the good stuff and it goes by and
it's gone and you haven't tasted it
and i really believe in that philosophy
if you don't if you don't at least
notice it
and and accentuate the good stuff when
the bad really tragic stuff comes along
it makes it it makes it tough to handle
i think people who are constantly
fetching about something
i think they they shorten their time
because
first of all they take all
well when you
when you find something let's say funny
or or or enjoyable
the whole body has a different attitude
it relaxes and that's got to be health
healthy to to to have that aspect as
opposed to the tension and the and the
worry and stuff i
i
i think optimism has a lot to do and i
learned that at my mom's knee
and my dad's
[Music]